[Musique]
c'est un fumet de poisson à la base on
appuie nos pétanque dans les fumées ont
déjà retiré on appuie les champignons
les sortir et on a desserré du et on y
est et on a créé mais est assaisonné de
vous lier avec toi avec un loup ont
creusé dans le débat ne fait rien
la coquille saint-jacques telle
qu'enseignée dans les écoles de cuisine
est un classique de la restauration
normalement on y retrouve entre 30 et
35% de pétantes et se nomme selon nos
réserves
donc on a 35 % prétend que dans la cas
qui donc c'est déjà beaucoup
on a 50 % fondateur et puis un peu de
champignons à peu sauf peut être en
marche
sur le marché on trouve des coquilles
saint jacques ont gelé prêtes à cuire et
également des coquilles qui contiennent
d'autres fruits de mer les crevettes ne
sont pas cuites nous avons demandé au
chef enseignant richard trottier et à
deux étudiants de l'école hôtelière de
laval d'analysé pour nous le contenu de
ces produits il y en a beaucoup de
coureurs l'auberge des cee plus enfouies
parmi cet échantillonnage de 14 produits
on retrouve les marques aliments passes
ta mère groupe alimentaire nordique
la fiche riz passion de la mer et
poissonnerie odessa fromage les portions
varie de 150 à 300 grammes une même
marque peut offrir plusieurs versions
pendant ce temps jean paul grappe réputé
chef enseignant à la retraite de lits
thq goûte avec nous deux des coquilles
et plus cher de notre échantillonnage
qu'est-ce que ça goûte c'est assez
insipide 1 est-ce que vous goûtez le
romain on prend vraiment les kakis de
fruits de mer de luxe là on a quand même
d'argentine que j'avais langouste omar
et pétoncles déjà mai 2009 par ce
mariage donne du boulot tu es à la sauce
non c'est nettement mieux que j'étais un
peu beaucoup un peu beaucoup moins une
coquille 900 mg de sodium
comme la plupart des aliments
transformés les coquilles de fruits de
mer ne font pas exception quant aux taux
élevés de sodium et d'additifs
rappelons que le taux quotidien maximum
recommandé de sodium et de 2004 100 mg
certains vont jusqu'à 800 à 900 1000 mg
de sodium
alors là c'est seulement un repas voire
une entrée un bien souvent donc ça c'est
le gros gros défauts mais je dirais
c'est le défaut de tous les aliments
prêts préparer
on trouve aussi de très nombreux
additifs alimentaires
ce qui est malheureux c'est quand vous
regardez dans la liste des ingrédients
aussi en a tellement d'ingrédients qui
va tuer le goût de fruits noirs qu'on
cherche dans une coquille en fait
mais globalement les grandes industries
vont ajouter ces agents de saveurs de
textures pour augmenter la durée de vie
du produit et beaucoup beaucoup
d'ingrédients qu'on n'a pas la maison un
des extraits de dioxyde de lécithine de
soja du colorant ya plein de trucs assez
pour prononçable la chason pour moi
vraiment l'industrie cherche à faire un
produit qui va imiter le produit maison
auquel on voit s'habituer quand on va
apprendre à apprécier et qui sera
peut-être même pas à base de poissons ou
si peu parmi ceux que j'ai regardé bain
dans passion de la mer le poisson arrive
en 20e position de la liste des
ingrédients
et ça c'est quand j'enlève tout le
contenu des parenthèses là c'est
vraiment maigre à offrir l'appui très
généreux en sauce c'est quoi cette
chaîne il ya zéro crevettes dedans nous
avons eu beaucoup de surprises sur le
total de fruits de mer
versus skip aux fruits noirs des fois ça
faisait générant près de moi mais comme
pour neuf et avec may cry avait beaucoup
plus de choses que de fruits noirs 12
des 14 co qui sont en-deça de 30 % de
fruits de mer
la coquille de fruits de mer de groupes
alimentaires nordique respecte le 30 %
de fruits de mer
mais on y trouve principalement de
limitation de crabes les crevettes et
les pétoncles se retrouvant au 21e et
22e rang des ingrédients et certaines
coques et il y avait des bobos sont
rumeurs d'aidé très bête entière des
grosses crevettes de pétanque et tagro
c'est le cas de la coquille du pêcheur
d'odessa qui avec son 75 % de fruits de
mer semble être la plus généreuse mais
gros bémol le premier ingrédient et du
simili crabes sur la base des
ingrédients il ya quelques compagnies
qui vont commencer avec du poisson et du
vrai poisson pour le choix moi je dirais
commencer la liste des ingrédients pc
trouver du vrai poisson ou des vrais
fruits de mer dans les trois quatre cinq
premiers ingrédients maximum de 185
autre constatation en pesant les
produits on voit que la majorité
n'atteint pas le point indiqué sur
l'emballage
mais la plupart restent dans les limites
tolérées par l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
nous avons par contre à visée odessa
qu'il manquait 80 grammes à une de ces
coquilles maison la compagnie a réagi
rapidement avec un grand
professionnalisme
en effet nous avons constaté des
différences au niveau des points nous
avons donc rencontré notre personnel
afin de discuter des méthodes de
fabrication ainsi que du contrôle de la
qualité pour être certains que cela ne
se reproduise plus pour chaque produit
qui n'auraient pas le poids réel indiqué
nous en feront don à l'organisme moisson
montréal
en résumé pour le prix demandé
les coquilles analysés contiennent peu
de vrais fruits de mer beaucoup de
sodium est énormément d'additifs
alimentaires
c'est pas un plaquage servirait à des
invités pour un grand jour de fête
très honnêtement je ne veux pas dire que
c'est pas bien mais pour manger tous les
jours pour un repas de quotidiens la
géorgie si je me mets ça chauffe eau ou
un seul est parfait l'utilité sept
frères vais à l'heure du repas je crois
que c'est une erreur
je crois sincèrement que c'est une
erreur et qu'il faut élaguer ailleurs
dans notre vie pour revenir un peu plus
souvent derrière les casseroles
[Musique]